[Musique]
se définir comme le leader mondial des
infrastructures de transport qui fait à
peu près 13 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires 60 000 employés et qui est
actif en France mais également dans 55
pays l'international pesant à peu près
60% de notre chiffre d'affaires le site
Manille labo et le lieu où le groupe
concentre toute sa recherche et
développement toute l'innovation donc
elle est centrée sur la route mais
également centrée sur des innovations de
rupture liées aux infrastructures de
transport comme par exemple watway qui
est une solution de
photovoltaïques intégrées à la chaussée
ou flowell qui est une solution de
marquage dynamique de la chaussée le
défi d'un grand nombre de pays
industrialisés où nous travaillons c'est
de remonter la qualité des
infrastructures routières les routes en
France étaient en 2011 classée numéro 1
en termes de qualité dans le monde elles
sont passées en quelques années à la 17e
place il est urgent de réinvestir de
l'argent dans la maintenance des routes
et de faire cette maintenance de façon
intelligente de façon prévisionnelle
avec une vision globale sur ça pour
réduire les coûts pour augmenter la
qualité et pour améliorer l'empreinte
environnementale qui ne peut qu'être
faite avec des responsabilités globales
sur la maintenance routière